les ukrainiens qui accuse par ailleurs
les russes d'avoir tiré des obus au
phosphore sur la petite ville de marine
cas les russes comment serait également
à se retirer du site nucléaire de
tchernobyl c'est ce qu'affirment les
américains bonjour cyril payen bonjour
vous étiez il ya encore quelques jours à
irbine vous en avez tiré d'ailleurs un
reporter la bataille dire pin à l'époque
il y a quelques jours donc la ville
était encore sous l'emprise russe depuis
elle a été libérée par les ukrainiens
quelle découverte en ont-ils fait bah
c'est l'heure des premiers bilans
effectivement pour ce genre de vilains
je rappelle qui est à 15 km au nord
ouest du centre de kiev le district dire
pin d'hosto mail bout de chacun qui ont
fait partie des premiers éléments de
l'offensive notamment des parachutistes
russes puisque c'était hautement
stratégique de prendre ces grandes
villes résidentiel on parle de ville
avec soixante dix mille habitants sur
des échelles très importante donc
effectivement avec georgia ce bug pour y
avoir passé une semaine ou plus fort de
la bataille aujourd'hui rpi
effectivement libéré je rappelle que
quand même on est dans une guerre aussi
informationnel quel que soit le camp et
qu'on ne peut pas il n'y a pas de
journalistes sur place que nous avons
quitté et repine c'était le dernier jour
où nous étions tolérée au front mais
effectivement le maire dira pin qui est
donc sain et sauf et et a déjà de 300
morts bilan au provisoire parmi les
civils donc c'est énorme par rapport à
ce flot de réfugiés qu'on avait pu voir
partir pour quitter ces districts la
moitié de la ville aussi et ça c'est
dramatique puisque c'est la moitié la
ville est détruite ça veut dire que
c'est hautement symbolique de ce que va
être la presse il ya un après quand il y
aura un après cette offensive russe la
moitié d'une ville résidentielle avec
1,1 mde des immeubles tout neuf qui ont
été complètement détruits que quand
comment va-t-on faire pour reconstruire
sa reconstruire des vies ça c'est la
vraie question qui se pose et puis
effectivement sur le plan militaire au
moment nous y étions il avait 1500
soldats des forces spéciales des
volontaires étrangers en grand nombre et
puis des forces de résistance
territoriale donc les ukrainiens qui
prenaient des fusils et bien il y a eu
beaucoup de pertes chez eux mais
effectivement les tanks russes n'avance
plus ont reculé la vraie question aussi
dans cette guerre informationnelle de
propagande c'est que sur le terrain et
nous avons des contacts quotidiens avec
les combattants sur place où des
habitants d'irbine qui ont décidé de ne
pas partir c'est que personne ne croit
aux promesses de cessez le feu aux
promesses de nouveau de corridors
humanitaires donné par moscou personne
ne croit à ce repli puisque on glose
beaucoup depuis le sommet de la
rencontre de turque en turquie pardon
sur l'europe le retrait des forces
russes tout le monde pense que c'est
juste une pause stratégique une pause
qui va permettre de réattaquer à un
moment anneaux dont chacun encore sur
ses gardes mais avec effectivement au
37e jour de cette offensive qui a frappé
le nord ouest de kiev avec un bilan
désastreux la moitié de la ville qui est
totalement détruite c'est la comète il
ya plein une autoroute plus
d'infrastructures et repique pour finir
était connue était célèbre puisque c'est
cette autoroute qui mène au centre ville
de kef pratiqué par des millions de
personnes qui avaient une un pont par
don sur la rivière pin et qui avait été
saboté à dessein le 25 février pour
stopper l'offensive russe donc tout cela
est encore une fois été stratégique
symbolique mais montre bien le devrait
destruction qui est malheureusement bien
plus important dans des villes comme
mario paul on l'a vu à l'instant et ça
montre aussi le degré de résistance des
ukrainiens vous parlez de repli mais il
ya aussi la résistance qui ne faut pas
oublier absolument mais ça c'est ce qui
restera évidemment c'est cette
formidable mobilisation populaire il y
avait notamment à irbine 2d des
combattants des volontaires qui ce qui
arrive est le plus possible pour
stratégiquement bloquer les russes mais
il y avait aussi beaucoup de deux civils
qui refusait tout simplement de partir
on a pu passer du temps dans des abris
avec des les appelle les babouchkas
d'aidé grand mère qui disait nous on
n'avait qu' on a connu les allemands il
ya 50 ans soixante dix ans les russes
attaque on ne partira pas et ce sont les
gens dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
s'ils sont encore vivants mais un esprit
de résistance totalement incarné par ces
vieilles générations ukrainienne qui
avait décidé de ne pas partir c'est en
ça que butch aoste e mail ir pin qui en
fait la ceinture de sécurité de kiev
sont hautement symbolique mais aussi
horriblement détruite par cette cette
guerre éclair merci beaucoup cyril je
vous invite à regarder votre reporter la
bataille dire pin sur youtube sur france
24 points comme également déjà vu par
plus de près de 5 millions de personnes
merci beaucoup cyril la thune